PETE: WE ARE BACK WITH A FIRST
ALERT.
AND A LIVE LOOK AT WALTER REED
HOSPITAL WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS UNDERGOING TREATMENT FOR
COVID-19.
THE PRESIDENT SHARED THIS
MESSAGE WHERE HEADING TO THE
HOSPITAL.
>> I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THE TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
I’M GOING TO WALTER REED
HOSPITAL, I THINK I’M DOING VERY
WELL.
BUT, WE’RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THINGS WORK OUT.
THE FIRST LADY IS DOING VERY
WELL.
SO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I WILL NEVER FORGET IT.
THANK YOU.
WILL: THE PRESIDENT’S DOCTOR,
ECHOING THOSE SENTIMENTS SAYING
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF IS DOING
VERY WELL AND, QUOTE, RESTING
COMFORTABLY AT WALTER REED
MEDICAL CENTER.
DR. SEAN CONLEY SAYS THE
PRESIDENT FINISHED FIRST DOSE OF
REMDESIVIR THERAPY.
HE WILL BE MONITORED AS HE
CONTINUES TO RUN THE COUNTRY
FROM THE HOSPITAL’S PRESIDENTIAL
SUITE.
JEDEDIAH: MEANWHILE MORE HIGH
PROFILE REPUBLICANS TEST
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19 INCLUDING
RNC CHAIRWOMAN RONNA McDANIEL
AND KELLYANNE CONWAY.
PETE: AND AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
UNDERGOES TREATMENT AT WALTER
REED, JOE BIDEN IS TURNING THE
DIAGNOSIS INTO WHAT HE BELIEVES
IS A FOR VOTERS.
>> THIS IS NOT A MATTER OF
POLITICS.
IT’S A BRAZEN REMINDER TO ALL OF
US THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS
VIRUS SERIOUSLY.
IT MEANS WEARING A MASK IN
PUBLIC AND IT MEANS ENCOURAGING
OTHERS TO DO SO AS WELL IT.
MEANS HAVING MASKING MANDATES
NATIONWIDE.
JEDEDIAH: HERE TO REACT GEORGIA
SENATE CANDIDATE AND CONGRESSMAN
DOUG COLLINS.
CONGRESSMAN, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
>> GOOD MORNING.
JEDEDIAH: I DIDN’T HEAR ANYTHING
DIFFERENT FROM JOE BIDEN.
THERE TO ME IT SEEMS LIKE PRETTY
CONSISTENT MESSAGING THAT HE HAS
HAD THROUGHOUT WITH THE ONE
CAVEAT THAT HE HAS PULLED DOWN
NEGATIVE ADS.
DO YOU THINK WHAT HE IS SAYING
HERE ABOUT A NATIONAL MASK
MANDATE WILL HAVE ANY MANDATE ON
VOTERS GIVEN WHAT HE HAS SAID
BEFORE.
>> NO.
LET’S BE HONEST WHEN YOU START
OUT BY SAYING THIS IS NOT ABOUT
POLITICS, IT’S ABOUT POLITICS.
IS HE USING A POINT TO MAKE
AGAINST WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
LOOK, HE HAS BEEN HIDING NUT
BASEMENT.
HE HAS BEEN IN A BASEMENT.
THIS IS HIS CHOICE.
THAT’S WHAT EXACTLY WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND HE HAS CHOSE TO DO
THAT AND STAY AWAY FROM THE
PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN OUT
LEADING.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TAKING
PRECAUTIONS.
YOU JUST GO AROUND THEY HAVE
BEEN DOING EVERYTHING THAT THEY
CAN AND THE PRESIDENT STILL GOT
IT.
WHAT WE’RE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
HERE THOUGH IS A REMINDER AS I
WAS HEARING EARLIER IN YOUR SHOW
TODAY WE DO AS A COUNTRY GOING
TO GET BACK OUT AND AS WE GET
BACK OUT THE THREAT IS STILL
HERE UNTIL WE HAVE A VACCINE.
WE NEED TO LEARN HOWE TO DEAL
WITH IT RESPONSIBLY.
WASHING HANDS, WEARING A MASK.
WHAT WE CAN DO.
WE CAN STILL DO THAT WHILE
GETTING BACK OUT AND RUNNING OUR
COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT IS SHOWING THAT.
PETE: YEAH, CONGRESSMAN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS STRIDE TO TRIE
STRIKE THAT BALANCE YOU NEED TO
BE RESPONSIBLE BUT GIVE YOU
INDIVIDUAL CHOICE.
OPENING UP AND RESPECT
BUSINESSES ARE RISK CALCULATIONS
AND RESPECTING THEIR CUSTOMERS.
HOW DO WE MAINTAIN OF OEA
TEMPTING TO REOPEN AND NOT SLIDE
BACKWARDS REFLECTIVELY AND
EMOTIONALLY AT THIS MOMENT.
>> WELL, IT’S GOING TO BE A
POSSIBILITY THAT PEOPLE WILL USE
THIS TO SAY NO, WE NEED TO GO
BACK.
AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT NUMBER ONE
HE HAS ALWAYS LED FROM THE
FRONT.
HE IS OUR PRESIDENT BUT HE IS
ALSO A MAN WHO IS NOW GOING TO
DEAL WITH THIS ALONG WITH THE
FIRST LADY AND OTHERS.
LET’S LOOK WAY IT’S GOING AROUND
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
DOCTRINE.
HERE IN GEORGIA BEEN OPENED UP A
LONG TIME MY NUMBERS IN MY
HOMETOWN ACROSS MY STATE GOING
DOWN, CONSISTENTLY GOING DOWN.
WE ARE SEEING IT MANAGED IN A
VERY RESPONSIBLE WAY.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE GOT TO
UNDERSTAND IS THERE IS ALSO A
POLITICAL COST BUT NOT ONLY AN
EMOTIONAL AND ECONOMIC COST TO
THIS IDEA THAT YOU JUST SHUT
DOWN EVERYTHING.
REMEMBER, SHUTTING DOWN
EVERYTHING WILL NOT GET RID OF
THIS VIRUS IT.
WILL SLOW THE VIRUS IT.
WILL STILL BE THERE.
WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT RESPONSIBLE
OPENING BUT RESPONSIBLE LIVING.
THE PEOPLE AND OUR ECONOMY HAS
TO HAVE THAT KEEPS US STRONG
WHILE WE KEEP PHYSICALLY AND
MENTALLY ECONOMICALLY TO THAT
POINT AS WELL.
WILL: SPEAKING OF NOT SHUTTING
DOWN, LET’S TALK ABOUT SENATOR
MITCH McCONNELL SAYING THE
SENATE WILL MOVE FULL STEAM
AHEAD IN THEIR NOMINATION
PROCESS, THEIR CONFIRMATION
PROCESS FOR JUDGE AMY CONEY
BARRETT.
IN YOUR ESTIMATION, THIS ORDER
OF BUSINESS, ALONG WITH, BY THE
WAY, A COVID-19 RELIEF BILL IN
THE HOUSE, WHERE ARE WE ON
MOVING FORWARD IN THE PROCESS OF
GOVERNANCE INSIDE OF CONGRESS?
>> WELL, REALLY, SINCE THE 116TH
CONGRESS STARTED GOVERNANCE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NOVEMBER
THIRD ELECTIONS WE HAVE GOTTEN
DOING THINGS FOR A LONG TIME SHE
NEVER GOT DOWN.
TO SAY WHEN IT CAME DOWN TO THIS
PAST WEEK OF FINDING RELIEF
PACKAGE.
SHE STUCK TO UNREALISTIC NUMBER
THAT ADDED MORE TO A POLITICAL
CALCULATION THAN IT DID ACTUALLY
HELPING BUSINESSES AND HELPING
PEOPLE.
SO, LOOK, I THINK THAT’S JUST
UNFORTUNATELY STUCK RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE NOMINATION OF AMY
CONEY BARRETT IS SOMETHING THAT
CAN MOVE FORWARD.
THEY CAN DO IT SAFELY.
THERE IS NO REASON THAT THIS
SHOULD STOP.
AND I BELIEVE THAT SENATOR
GRAHAM WILL ACTUALLY HOLD THOSE
HEARINGS.
WE WILL GET IT ONTO THE FLOOR
AND IT WILL BE VOTED ON BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
YOU CAN DO THAT THE PROBLEM I
HAVE HAD WITH CONGRESS RIGHT NOW
WE VIEWED OURSELVES ESPECIALLY
SPEAKER PELOSI AND OTHERS HAVE
VIEWED OURSELVES AS SOMETHING
OTHER THAN ESSENTIAL PART OF
GOVERNMENT AND THAT THEY CAN
CENTRALIZE CONTROL IN
LEADERSHIP.
THE PROBLEM IS WE ALL NEEDED TO
BE THERE WE ALL NEEDED TO TAKE
TESTS AND TAKE PRECAUTIONS WE
COULD ACTUALLY DO OUR JOB.
PEOPLE NEED TO SEE CONGRESS IN
ACTION.
THEY DIDN’T SEE THAT ESPECIALLY
FROM THE HOUSE IN THE LAST
LITTLE BIT.
WILL: A LOT OF THE BUSINESSES
AND PEOPLE NEED HELP UNDER
MANDATES TO SHUT DOWN THEY COULD
USE A GOVERNMENT RELIEF EFFORT
WHEN IT COMES TO COVID-19.